hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
survival means the continuance of life
life is she says not even a value it is
that which you have to have in order for
there to be values so she's got this you
know contrast up could a robot actually
value anything no because there's
nothing that it stands to lose it's not
actually a lot living things can convey
lis other things and she says value is
is that which one acts to gain or key
that's not primary it presupposes an
answer to certain other questions so
from live we get to values and we can
she speaks of a hierarchy of values in
different places what's a hierarchy may
have a higher yeah exactly so you can
set up you know like um if I already
asked you so here's a departmental
office actually not as big a milk
chocolate dark chocolate which is more
important this or this should I you know
somebody comes up to me doctor said well
give it two of these there give me this
I'd be an idiot right there's a higher
two there in place how many how many
iPhones would say replace a good
friendship I don't know if you have to
ask that question you're probably not
really that close of a friend with the
person anyway aren't you because
friendship a genuine friendship would be
in a higher level you can set up a
hierarchy of your your values and every
one of you he has a number of values but
those values ultimately have to for for
rands
purposes serve life serve you stayin
alive and survival is
they often miss the Hertz effect to
check them it's survival all that we we
have to focus on that there's staying
alive and that's that's good you don't
stay alive the whole question of values
is what else yeah yeah and a lot of that
has to do with the survival so I got to
eat I have to have water I need shelter
yeah yeah no she's gonna frame happiness
in terms of emotions and talk about that
a little bit later on but the way in
which she's going to understand this has
to do with living a fully rational human
living a rational human life actually
exploring and developing the potential
that we have what are what are things
that are distinctively human that we do
that the other the animals aren't able
to do they don't yeah reason there
there's a big one that I'm trying to
sort of unpack what goes into the reason
though for reasoning thinking about
things I've been dogs think a little bit
casting conscious conscious Oh like a
moral conscience like distinguishing
right wrong yeah we have I'll get to
yours on a second we have a conception
of you know more right wrong a dog has a
conception of I shouldn't do this
because I get smacked enough the knows
what I do and I should do this because I
got a cookie that we go way beyond that
right so that that's that's a good
yes another thing that animals kind of
do I mean insects don't really choose at
all there are lower animals as we get
higher and higher and closer to us there
seems to be something more like a choice
but it's not it's not like a dog either
sits down and makes a teacher and says
[Music]
cause trouble don't cause trouble what
are the what are the benefits for the
feels we do things right and then we
also talk with each other they consult
each other what do you think about this
do that because we have you know a lot
of capabilities then go far beyond
they're merely the animal nature and
they come out of animal so there are
some distinctively human aspects to a
full life and part of that includes
choosing to think what she says and
thinking is in fact that she says
volition
it means involves will it involves
commitment she seems to talk is that
most people don't think wherever they
get them but really what she she's
advocating is that we want to think out
what our values should be what is way to
serve why what is going to get us on the
way to a particular human life enjoying
and then choose those and arrange the
things in order so for example social
approval you know most of us want other
people to like us to approve of us very
few people don't some people really
don't and they enjoy making other people
angry and irritated but they're the
minority if social approval matters to
you that's a value right are there other
things that should take precedence over
that if you want to live a rational or
even you just want survive in the
society that we live in social approval
get you killed but it could lead you to
some problems drinking too much
chocolate for you right you might drink
too much because you're hanging out with
people you know be a group and be
considered a fun person that's probably
not going to kill you but it will be not
diminish later but other a lot of things
were using integer
you know trade-off of rational life
think about getting your ideas from
whatever it is society gives you as
opposed to thinking that out for
yourself and choosing what you want to
value instead of just having other
people give you what you should be
that's you know there's a valuation
going out there one is supposed to be
higher than the other you have to choose
one or the other for any of these sort
of things so you know she talks about a
bunch of different she leads us from you
know the bacteria all the way up to
human beings you know having goals like
nature you know and what she's really
interested in is life is AM ultimate
value the goal or the end which all
other lesser goals or the means this
should set the standard for all of this
stuff over here is where we do our oral
decisions actions these can become
habits for us this is where we make our
choices this is where we live our life
over here is the you know the standard
if something is going to improve my life
then it's good for me if something
improves lives for human beings in
general it's good for human beings in
general would be how this way do you see
how this sort of approach and gets you
out of the problem with the egoism
wherever you would be we'll look you've
got this sort of
you know desires and and priorities and
preferences I've got this set they don't
really match up there is no good overall
they're good overall this light and not
conducive stall we need us to employ
life so by contrast anything that gets
in the wake of that is going to be what
aunty life and therefore irrational and
therefore damn morally death they after
us they have to do they had to encourage
others to do so she says you know life
is the only phenomenon that's an end in
itself the concept of value is dependent
on and derived from the concept of life
to speak of value as a perk from life is
worse than a contradiction in terms very
given the hyperbole it is only the
concept of life that makes the concept
of value possible so now some people
would say there's certain values that
should take precedence over life itself
or some things that you ought to
sacrifice yourself to that's part of
what she's trying to criticize an attack
so you know she says she's a big critic
of religion for example some people
think of religion this way I'm not gonna
say anybody here are necessarily does
this is kind of a reductive way of
looking at it but a value for you could
be getting in good with God being on
God's good side not really on God's bad
side you know when you picture God is
like the big guy in the sky the
lightning bolts that's actually Zeus
that's not really you know Old Testament
New Testament God but but that's close
enough and if you picture you know life
that way then the top value would be
being on God's good side and you figure
that out through you know
the sorority and maybe you should
sacrifice your life to that or your
rationality to that Ram would say well
that's putting the cart before the horse
values are supposed to serve life not
life that is you could do the same thing
for other values as well she's very
critical of hedonism the moral theories
that say that we should pursue pleasure
the spider is a valuable anybody here
that doesn't like pleasure doesn't like
enjoying things have too much enjoyment
in your life too much satisfaction
probably not right
could you could you all use a little bit
more pleasure in here day but I can do
all of you improve your day well the
pleasure is a value but do you want a
subordinate life to just pursue pleasure
they would be living a kind of in human
existence you would not be developing
what's distinctively human in that case
and to say that that's the way to go
that would be a mistake now if she gives
you some criteria for figuring out what
actually is yeah she says um pleasure
and pain form a part of that you know I
had a basic physical level and also to a
certain degree psychological level so if
I do something dumb like look around
there's a very safe classroom I was able
to make up an example so there's like
you know there's some pins in the cork
board a little said what what peanut to
Mike why not just Mike and Pauly is that
hurts right you've all done stuff like
that at one point or another when I was
a kid I actually took my mom's car keys
and stuck it into the electrical socket
when we do that once right because it
knocked me backwards everything turned
blue for a while the key got really hot
got really worried in them very have I
learned that's a bad idea
don't do that sort of thing and in
general things that are going to screw
up your life tend to hurt right if you
think of all the things that you enjoy
drinking and now think of things would
be bad for you to drink like hydrogen
peroxide that would probably wouldn't
kill you I don't think it's poisonous
but can't be good right my grandparents
when they were kids they used to gargle
with the kerosene is you had a cold that
was the careful gargle with kerosene
they said it tasted a lot but not as bad
as gasoline so that means that they also
died
well there's lots of things that we do
you know how do we know they shouldn't
bend your finger you know further back
ministers it hurts and how do you know
that you should eat a certain amount
each day because you're gonna get hungry
and that's gonna hurt right how do you
know you shouldn't eat too much well
your stomach it's super full and then
you know that hurts too or you lay
around you can't give anything that this
is very simple stuff right but how do we
know what's good for us
generally and there's some traps with
this right like say heroin generally
they're Pleasant heroin is not good for
us you know but it's fantastic but most
things that are good for us are pleasant
most things that taste good at least you
know if we're relying on very simple
food are actually good for us most
things that actually tastes quite bad
are probably not good for us to eat
we've kind of screwed that up with you
know how we put fat sugar and salt into
everything but you get the general idea
so she says this pleasure pain mechanism
serves as a sort of guardian of the
organisms life and then beyond that you
have consciousness as it means of
survival we start thinking out what do I
need and eventually we get to the point
distinctively rational human thought and
you realize that you need for example
shelter
well you're gonna have to build a
shelter so you better use your head to
figure out what's going to work
can can you use anything whatsoever to
build a shelter we device' you know it's
now survivor we're on the island yet
still remember that show this is our raw
material these desks and we'll start you
know sending the water down from the sky
ceiling in a couple minutes
could you make a good shelter out of
these desks probably not probably be
smarter to figure out you know who's got
jackets and stuff like that we put those
over it we do a little bit of thinking
all right this will be like our roof
won't keep the rain out of it always
keep most of it of hot ones well that's
again serving life yeah that is
something that requires an effort to do
not everybody necessarily does that
animals do what they do by instinct we
reason and we have to choose to actually
use reason so you know like she says an
animal has no choice in the standard of
value directing its actions its sense is
provided with an automatic code of
values we're different we don't have an
automatic code of values because of our
more complicated nature we're sort of
like what she calls a table rasa blank
slate we have to make which says man is
no automatic quota survival is no
automatic course of action the automatic
set values his own consciousness has to
discover the answers to all these
questions but as consciousness
automatically got to choose to think
yeah that is the basis at least as far
as life and values go and rands
ethical you know theory which is
rational he do it
you